I think the right to vote is inherent to
our democracy yes even for terrible
people
well those terrible people that Sanders
think should have gotten the right to
vote include the Boston Marathon bomber
along with child rapists and murderers
his plan is so deranged that even these
guys are shocked I was stunned as you
could see you could see on our faces and
the responses if you have creative
committed a crime like the Boston
Marathon bombings or if you just you've
assaulted or abused a child I don't
think Americans would most Americans
would want people like that to you know
what it frames it frames the proposition
for voters as these people are way out
there in the Democratic Party Wow Bagon
far left mmm when these guys say it but
hey it gets crazier Alexandria Acacio
Court says his chief of staff now
offering his thoughts in each we did
this
what's the reason not to let
incarcerated people vote shouldn't the
people most affected by unjust laws have
some say in electing people to change
them so now we're at the point where the
Democratic Party thinks the laws if at
the Boston Marathon bomber behind bars
are unjust they somehow fails to
understand that if those are truly
unjust laws it's up to Congress to
change them here to debate David bossy
former Trump deputy campaign manager and
Fox News contributor an attorney Alan or
Alan I'm gonna start with you because
I'd love to get an insight from a
Democrat and tell me is what I just saw
a sane proposal for the Democrats to run
on in 2020 right so I think when you are
talking about Bernie Sanders
specifically he's talking about what
they already do in Vermont in Maine so
they already have the place where these
people can vote when they're even when
they're in Carson what kind of crime no
matter what type of crime murder that's
today right currently today you can just
go ahead and vote while you're still
incarcerated there are some levels in
which they might exclude people but most
people are allowed to vote in those
circumstances that's okay that's his
circumstance you're happy that's what
yeah I'm asking you you're asking what
my thought is absolutely so I think that
there because of the the prison system
that we have new rhythm complex that we
built we need to start may allow some
people to vote there should be some
people that are excluded
but specifically after people have done
their time they should be allowed to
vote after they've done their time
that's a big difference David it's
different to say after you've done your
time you've proven yourself to be a
responsible person I'm all about
restorative justice I worked on this
committee with the president and the
people involved I'm totally for that but
we're not talking about people who have
been restored we're talking about people
are sitting there because they murdered
people this is outside of the mainstream
this is outside of common sense Bernie
Sanders wasn't talking just about
Vermont he was talking about all people
across the country that are incarcerated
so that would include Nicholas Cruz the
Parkland murderer who murdered 16 kids
in that school in parkland Florida you
know we have we have the Son of Sam
sirhan sirhan is still in prison are we
expecting that these people the worst of
the worst
are now going to be able to vote it is
insane policy but it is so good for
Donald Trump to have to be able to run
against that because it the American
people were rejected yeah I only speak
to that I don't think the American
people are gonna reject the concept of
saying that most people are in prison
never had a trial 90 percent of them
never we're before court many of them
took go alpha before it's even the issue
the issue is Bernie Sanders is saying
people who've done evil things and we're
talking to Boston bomber Boston so
you're talking about the people that are
convicted we know that there are rapists
and murderers they have not been
convicted do they vote every day and we
know these people who were before they
were convicted for voting every day and
voting was not essentially a part of
their crime so people can be alcoholics
and still be good lawyers got it so
here's the thing why is it Democrats
want inmates to vote more so do they
think that more of the inmates are
Democrats is I mean is that what I don't
think that's really a whole story in any
court I think that what they're saying
is that people who have been
disenfranchised because 30% of the
population of people of color but they
represent 60% of the jail weight and so
therefore these laws and these
institutions are impacting these
individuals in their papers because they
were convicted in a court of law that's
what our system a where it didn't hold
on when you are in prison you lose your
right of assembly you'd lose your First
Amendment rights you lose a lot of right
to lose your second you lose your second
right you'd lose your right to vote
that's what law-abiding citizens get to
do those that are incarcerated do not
and they ought not to be able to vote
and they ought not to look this is a
conversation that we are glad to
actually out of time we could talk about
this for a long time
and I'm sure we will during the break